the biggest mistake I see people make on
social media now is inconsistency of
posting I see a lot of this maybe they
went to an event or they listened to a
podcast or they watched one of your
videos and they got really stoked and
they're like okay I'm going to create
content and they go and they create a
piece of content every single day and
then they can't keep it up because
something happens and then they give up
on it and then a week later they come
back from not posting and they're like
I'm back I took a week away from social
media no one knew that you were gone so
you don't need to tell people that
you're back that's just telling people
that you're inconsistent